a Las Vegas man is in jail tonight after
he was arrested all in connection with a
deadly high-speed crash we thank you for
joining us at 11 on this Friday night
I'm Brian Loftus now police say he was
driving nearly 100 miles an hour when he
hit a wall happened near Nellis in Lake
Mead many in that area say this isn't
the first time something like this has
happened Sasha Loftus joins us live
she's at the Clark County Detention
Center Sasha joins us with more tonight
Brian the man arrested in connection
with this crash is here at CCDC tonight
police say this situation one of many
similar crashes happened this year
involving speed and suspected impairment
now those we spoke with tonight say it's
concerning especially ahead of the
holidays
it's just scary this is bad people
living in the Northeast Valley share
their concern over continued crashes
people need to slow down this holiday
season slowly on the latest took a
woman's life here on Nellis near Lake
Mead
police say 21-year-old Jesus Martinez
Ruiz was driving 98 miles per hour when
he lost control of his truck and crashed
into this brick wall just after midnight
Friday 24 year old Jennifer Soto Cruz
who according to reports was not wearing
a seat belt died on the scene based on
the serious nature of the underlying
offense Martinez Ruiz is now facing DUI
charges after officers say he admitted
to smoking marijuana and drinking before
he got behind the wheel if you're
drinking get an Uber it's a story many
here call unsettling but not surprising
while deadly DUI crashes are down
compared to this time last year those
involving excessive speed have seen a 28
percent jump that's what I'm also
worried about as well once I start
driving you know when I get on the road
having to deal with that their numbers
many say they'll keep in mind next time
they head out on the road flying up and
down Lake Middle Nellis at 100 miles an
hour as dangerous to keep themselves and
those they love safe
now Martinez Ruiz is facing Martinez
Reese is facing multiple charges
including DUI resulting in death
reckless driving and driving without a
valid driver's license he is due back in
court this coming Tuesday reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now